[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Tannenbaum the former general
manager former NFL executive appears
regularly on many of ESPN Studio
programs and uh one of the smarter NFL
people I've ever been around Mike joins
us on the program Mike I was uh
mentioning this prior to the commercial
break I thought the big winner one of
the big Winners yesterday was tuatanga
Viola because at the start of the Season
it felt like the dolphin said if this
doesn't go well we still have some draft
picks and we could use that to take a
quarterback here and you're going to
probably pick up his fourth year you
know his option here after this next
season with what he's doing this year
what do you think the Dolphins said
about two of without saying anything
yesterday yeah Dan great to be with you
and I completely agree with you you know
it's interesting when you look at next
year's first round Seattle with Geno
Smith playing really good Philadelphia
who has jalenhurst playing well and then
Houston in Detroit those are the four
teams that have two first round picks
and now Miami is one of five teams that
doesn't have a first round pick so I
completely agree with you I think they
send a massive message that hey two is
our guy and look let's face it when he's
healthy he's played well this year now
if I'm them I have to hold my breath a
little bit in terms of can he get
through the rigors of a 17 Game season I
would fortify the offensive line but
clearly when you look at winners and
Lewis losers I would put two at the very
top
uh Bradley Chubb going to the Dolphins
and I understand Denver's saying all
right we're not going anywhere we're not
going to pay this guy 100 million
dollars I guess moving forward uh give
me the logic of what Denver did and uh
what Miami is doing
I don't like it for Denver because it
sends the wrong message which is hey we
acquired Russell Wilson we should be
trying to win as many games as possible
it sends a terrible message that hey
even though we may have hit on Baron
Browning and certainly Randy Gregory was
a big off-season acquisition
Bradley Chubbs a young
really productive pass rusher when he's
healthy so I want to keep those players
even if I have to franchise them now
look I'm sure what they're saying is we
need a first round pick to help with the
offensive line or other ways to help
Russell but that's San Francisco's first
rounder and Dan they're going to be
playing meaningful games I wouldn't be
surprised if San Francisco's first round
pick was in the lower 20s and for Miami
I like it from a standpoint of even
though you have Jalen Phillips and
Emmanuel agba you've really struggled
getting to the quarterback and for us to
get to where we want to go we gotta beat
Josh Allen we got to be Patrick Mahomes
and if we were drafting in next year's
first round as you mentioned if we're
good on two uh pass rush is the likely
place they would have gone anyway
give me the move that happened or didn't
happen that will have the biggest impact
on the end of the the end of the season
you know Dan it's easy for me I mean
it's shocking that we're talking about
an NFC North team adding a wide receiver
and it's not the Green Bay Packers you
know one of the things like when you
have the privilege of running an NFL
team you have to have the wherewithal to
say hey our plan is firmly etched in
pencil and we're gonna move on from
Devonte Adams we're going to take
Christian watts in the second round
Romeo Dobbs in the fourth but we have an
all-time great quarterback right now
who's much closer to the end than the
beginning so go get Jerry Judy go get
Chase Claypool go help him win right now
and the fact that the Packers didn't to
me is very meaningful where look the
Bears aren't going to win the division
but Claypool is going to be a good
player that helps Justin fields and then
you've got Minnesota sitting there with
six wins Dan and they add a good player
in TJ Hawkinson but I don't understand
if if it's obvious to us Mike then why
didn't the Packers make a move
well you know the word on the street was
they were interested in Claypool
um and maybe they just felt it wasn't
worth a second round pick and look I've
been there with Brett Favre I've been
there with Vinnie testavery with
quarterbacks at the end of their career
and when those windows are closing you
want to do everything within reason and
I think what happens sometimes in Green
Bay is you can lack a sense of urgency
because you don't have an owner and look
they've done a great job Matt leflore
Brian guticon stay have a really good
record I just think they
made a mistake by not doing you know
what a lot of other teams did yesterday
which is to help them coming down the
stretch here now with that said Dan if
they come out of this with Odell Beckham
Jr in the next week or two you know then
we'll give them credit then but that's
the one player that's out there of
consequence that can help them in a
meaningful way Chase Claypool frustrates
me
because I think he looks the part he
doesn't always play the part
why is that
a lot of young receivers come out of
college exactly that way they're not
great route Runners they're also very
young somewhat immature
um he's a guy that let's face it
um had some growing up to do which I
think he was starting to do that I think
there was some humility that guys like
George Pickens were just getting more
playing time and sometimes when you go
to the next team you benefit like I know
when we acquired San Antonio homes that
was humbling for him to get traded from
the Steelers to the Jets so it could be
an opportunity and really what I would
tell him if I was a gym in the bear
stand is very simple like
the Slate is completely clean you can
grow in a meaningful way with Justin
fields for the next 10 years and make a
lot of money right here in Chicago or in
a year and a half you could be on your
third team in three years and be a
journeyman so the pen is in your hand
what kind of career do you want to have
and I couldn't help but think of Laramie
Tunstall yesterday because of the draft
Capital that you got for Laramie
Tunstall and that turns out that you're
able to use it for Bradley Chubb Jalen
model and Tyreek Hill that seems like a
one-sided trade if you looked at you
know a lot of times we look at trades
Mike and we go oh man they got the
better end of this because we look at
what happens immediately you got to play
the long game sometimes where you go oh
that's right they got those draft picks
from the Texans for Laramie Tunstall and
that's one of the reasons candidly Bill
O'Brien is not in use anymore Bill
O'Brien may be a good coach but he
turned out not to be a good GM you know
with the tonsil trade DeAndre Hopkins
amongst the others so
um you know credit Miami for doing that
and and when you look at even the trade
back where they traded back
um with the 49ers when San Francisco
trade up last year for Trey Lance they
came out out with both Jalen waddle
Tyree kill so they have some great
players in Hill waddle and Chubb the
question for Miami now is can Tua stay
at that level consistently and healthy
can chubs stay healthy which he's
struggled with and now we got these
pieces can we close the gap meaningfully
on Kansas City and buffalo and I'll go
back to the deals that were made by two
other teams in the NFC North if you
would have said two teams are going to
pick up receivers in the NFC North uh I
know a lot the Lions aren't going to be
one of those you would have assumed that
it would be the Packers and the Vikings
and the fact that it's the Bears and the
Vikings and TJ Hawkins mentioned for a
team that had no production from their
tight ends
I thought this was a sneaky great pickup
for them absolutely and TJ Hawkinson Dan
he's a really good blocker like he could
capture the edge and by the way you got
Dalvin cook so you could close games out
so that was a really good move and by
the way like I've been in Brian gouda
comes to shoes to jam the Packers like
he's walking into that building today
and he's got 53 guys look at him like
what's going on here like what what what
didn't you do like we want to win right
now and look you gotta do things within
reason and be judicious we get that Dan
but what happens when Rogers passes
Brian goodacunst in the hallway
it's not it's not good and I gotta tell
you I had great relationships with like
some of the veterans like the BART Scots
of the world I remember I we once cut a
player Jericho katri who was a b player
and an A-Plus person and we moved on
from him because we we needed the spot
and I had like an
lying in my office like you screwed up
Mike you can't do that this guy solves
problems for you and I can't imagine
today Ann Rogers is pounding down that
door like what didn't you get done like
why do you think we're a better team
today we know Watson can stay healthy
Dobbs has been really inconsistent why
not go get a guy like Claypool or Judy
or Brandon Cooks like why didn't you do
that like it sends a horrible message
now with that said the one thing they
could do is go get Odell Beckham because
look I know he's coming off of the ACL
he's not ready yet but when he played in
the last game we saw Dan including Aaron
Donald he was the best player on the
field and he just turned 30. so I think
there's still good football left in him
and that's exactly the type of player
they need yeah but he makes me nervous
that's two ACLS Mike and and coming from
somebody who's had seven knee surgeries
and I'm just trying to walk let alone
he's going out there trying to play
after his second one and I know a lot of
people hold out of Hope and and he's
click bait they love to follow the
stories uh speaking of Click bait the
Cowboys I guess we're all in on Brendan
Cooks to the very end and then didn't
pull the trigger I know it's expensive
he's productive how surprised were you
the Cowboys didn't make this move really
surprised they have a championship
defense you know outside of Aaron Donald
I think Micah Parsons may be the best
non-coreback on the planet he he is that
Transcendent and when you have a window
to win now look your quarterback Dan we
could debate is that the sixth best
score back the 12th it really does
matter he's a good quarterback with a
great defense and if you could get one
more element on the perimeter that could
really help guys like CD Lam and look
like Dalton Schultz is good not great
but you do have Tony Pollard they are
missing like I think if they can have
the one move back it would moving on
from Cooper was really a mistake because
that's really what they need they need
somebody on the outside that can make
plays and that's what Brandon Cooks can
do he can take the top off coverage he
can move the safety over it opens up the
middle of the field and I think
in hindsight that one of cut Cooper was
making just 20 million dollars which is
reasonable in this day and age and I
would have extended a little bit to make
sure that we at least gotten Cooks
talking to Mike Tannenbaum the ESPN NFL
front office Insider yeah trying to
figure out what the Cowboys were doing
and I thought you know Jerry loves shiny
toys and you bring in another offensive
weapon but let me go back to Micah
Parsons you guys spend so much time
studying who these you know draft
eligible players are
he's a middle linebacker at Penn State
had tremendous athleticism
it I go back to Aaron Donald like some
of these guys where you go how did
people Miss on them
so Donald's easy he isn't tall and he
plays a position that let's face it
isn't a premier position me he wasn't
like a pass rushing defensive end so
that's why he wasn't a top five pick
there was real concerns that he was a
little bit short and coming out he
wasn't overly big obviously that was a
massive mistake Parsons is really
interesting because Dan like
it was a negative a little bit coming
out he was a little bit positionless
from a standpoint you're right he was an
off the ball middle linebacker at Penn
State so you actually couldn't see what
he could do great which was rush the
passer and sometimes that happens like
players play in different positions in
college and I think look he's a great
player but I give Dan Quinn a lot of
credit because what he's been able to do
is move him around and just puts him in
like he gets him in a lot of one-on-one
situations and he's unblockable and look
they got DeMarcus Lawrence last year
they also had Randy Gregory but when you
get Parsons one-on-one he's hard to
block and you didn't see that a lot at
Penn State you saw him dropping you
could see him run you you could see the
athleticism but now what we're seeing it
translate to a great pass rusher as well
I thought that they would use him in
college like they did LaVar Arrington
where you just say hey we're going to
line him up you try to find him because
he's coming after you and and that's
where and I did have a source who said
if somebody's willing to take the chance
Micah Parsons is uh the best defensive
player in the draft
and
we've we've seen that I mean he should
be up there in the MVP race
you know Dan if we if we owned a team
and it wasn't a quarterback I'm
hard-pressed to think he wouldn't be the
guy we would start our team up
oh
I like that hey it's great to talk to
you as always and uh thanks for joining
us Mike
yeah I'd really appreciate it and I hope
those 7D surgeries serve you well and uh
yeah yeah that you would take me off the
board
way too many red flags not just my knees
by the way but you you would have taken
me off the board but then you got great
intangibles
thank you buddy that's Mike Tannenbaum
the ESPN NFL front office Insider former
NFL executive